welcome this video playing over craft
that may be in the Queens gambit try
something else can almost pretty move c5
they're almost like a CD 5 but if white
is not playing c5 like almost invariably
going to play c5 himself okay taking
with the night
Wow okay let's rather risky
hmm there are lines with Lana castles
but not here not really here so 94 I
guess this waveform has lines with long
castles but usually with Bishop e7 and
stab Bishop e7 and then c5 not after
night bd7 here the black counter play
with the Knights it's coming really
quickly okay Wow why is that even
working can check your ID check and now
i have i have night before
yeah it's possible at least you can also
take f6 I don't see I don't see anything
great their home if I take it take with
the bishop right before it's still a
threat ok so here was thinking bishop
eddie seven maybe push ups III know it's
not a problem so I can do this but sure
Bishop d7 is good tending Bishop a 4
mmm the bishop a for Queen a three it's
not that clear actually
now I didn't play that the chat didn't
play that well no this is far more than
he ever should have gotten yeah it's not
working one bit but let's see Ponting's
and I think I can do it f6
Queenie 5f 627 and then I'm going to
probably made him with Queen hm queen a
135 has also Queen at you and I also
have Bishop f5 him as an as an
additional move I actually could have
played that 195 already maybe then it
can drop back yeah so I think it was ok
to to take the night you know check ok
so at least here I don't have to think
so no checks get this chicken check
check white resides I was a provisional
okay so yeah I think long castles that's
just not working at all I mean we'll
need to lead to problems g-form yeah
maybe the other night is actually even
better than that it is good job static
steaks sure have sex here night before
yeah computer greased up to here but now
it wants to take care yeah mmm-hmm I
could have already seen that move and
would have been quite strong actually
yeah ok I hope that my move doesn't
screw it up no check hey that's that's
actually minus 50 Kim check check as I
didn't play it too badly yeah long
castling him I mean no canceling is in
general quite risky in the Queens gambit
I mean you have played d4c form there of
course lines where is completely okay
yes it's just something that has to be M
yeah considered carefully as if the
center is opened
did the King feels uncomfortable on the
CFR quite often you hear he didn't even
find time for move like King be one okay
thanks for watching